you're watching screen junkies central
this episode is brought to you by mafia
3 family is who you die for and e-signal
oh my goodness screen junkie central
make some noise San Diego
oh man this is non-stop one fun panel
after another um
dare I say it's an embarrassment of
riches Andy are you having a fun con and
I'm excited for this next show because
it looks really funny yeah this is one
of the most unique cool-looking shows
that I've seen come along seam come
down the pike it along one of my
favorites it comes right now his last
man on earth isn't even watching that
one oh it's so good and Lord and Miller
making that this is their next new show
yeah horn oh and we're really lucky to
have so many funny people so many
involved in this show and yeah I'm
really excited
son of zorn we've got so much of the
cast the creators let's go ahead and
introduce ready let's do it
you know from Curb Your Enthusiasm she's
the wonderful talented funny Cheryl hi
welcome great to meet you watch your
step
coming up hello great to see you
oh one of our favorites from Saturday
Night Live and so many other great
things Tim Meadows oh wow welcome and
thank you thanks for being here
oh the lovely delightful I know we love
him my friend Johnny Pemberton yes yeah
good to see you Johnny and she is one of
the executive producers of the show
Sally Bradford McKenna and the director
of the show Eric a pal oh wow Wow so you
guys happy comic-con is this anybody's
first comic-con it's mine
you're kidding me not kidding you Cheryl
hi how are you are you loving it is it
overwhelming what's the deal um it's
very entertaining I like all the
costumes and the enthusiasm it's pretty
adorable oh well you're pretty adorable
if you were going to and I love you like
I was I I knew you way back when I met
you at The Groundlings cuz I was over
there and this is such a funny panel
like UCB Saturday Night Live just stand
up everything um but okay I want to ask
you okay if you were gonna cosplay as
one thing what would it be Cheryl Hines
what's the question
if you were gonna dress up as a
character yeah
cosplay is where you wear a costume for
play cost - yeah I was Austrian for
actually that's what I've been trying to
understand is why do people dress up and
walk around just sex stuff okay then
I'll go at Wonder Woman oh yeah classic
right awesome let's go down the line and
everybody tell us if you were gonna
Cosway as something don't you're not
allowed to say ladies man okay no have
you seen the rear that comic book call
it's Agra sagar yeah
I would want to be the guy he's dead now
I think actually spoiler alert what's
his name the Brent he's the one he had a
war trenchcoat he was a killer he was
looking for the yes okay so you go
around the guy who stole a baby yes I
can't think it a character's name I want
to say it's the Brent or something like
that I'll look it up deep cut though
yeah
Johnny deep cut I would probably deep
cut love deep deep he searches all
through the vinyl shops of America
finding the greatest forgotten b-sides
deep cut aural Carmen Elektra or Carmen
Electra that'd be great
I'll be the Dennis Rodman - you're
Carmen Electra and let me Sally oh yeah
hopefully be a lot of sons don't cosplay
next year and Eric Oh would you dress up
as alternate 1985 awesome or Donald
Trump I love that so this is a brand new
show tell us a little bit about the
conceit of this show merging live-action
with animation and and the story behind
it the character's name is the will by
the way that's the character's name what
was the question about Cheryl the
question is what's that what is son of
Zord
it's one of the first hybrid
live-action/animated show Thank You
sheriff and it's it's basically a family
show but just at the center of it it's
we've won animated characters arm
bass voice by Jason Sudeikis and he's
just coming back to reconnect with his
ex-wife and his son
these two beyond thing and yeah we
really excited for people check it out
soon
it's like a world where you know like an
old 80s style action cartoon hero has a
family of real live-action people it's
very weird bizarre show to explain the
concept is so awesome though it's just
it's insane and tell us about the
influences obviously I would think like
you know 80s animation he-man or yeah
just I mean basically all of those you
know Thunder the Barbarian and the
barbarian Thundercats oh yeah there's
Cheetara combination the animation style
by the way tip Mouse is our animation
studio effect people know titmouse
they're amazing yeah it's it's it's sort
of a combination of like all these all
these old cartoons that you know we grew
up watching and fell in love with it's
this classic like 2d animated style and
it's like almost like Roger Rabbit
integration you know yeah which is a
crazy it's I think it looks awesome and
it looks like how did that get on the
air but I imagine the Lord and Miller
right at which yeah amazing talented
what's it like working with them oh
they're amazing
yeah notes on all the stories all the
cuts and yeah they weigh in on basically
everything and and yeah they're really
really chilled to work with and if not
for them like this show it's such a
bizarre show the track record those guys
have like they are the reason that the
show you know got made it's a real leap
to do a crazy show like this but they
they make things work that you know
people are normal yeah that shouldn't
work that's awesome and I just wonder
logistically on the day of shooting is
so Jason Sudeikis voices Zorn right is
he actually there or do you have just
like a guy and like a green suit with
like motion cat or what well we actually
have Dan Lippert Dan lip burn ICP
theater
yeah yeah I have no idea yeah yeah dan
Lippert it's it's a such a complicated
process when we shoot the show so we
have this actor comedian Dan Lippert
played Zorn
on set and he's a tall dude was five
yeah
so we shoot a rehearsal take with him
you should say he's wearing he's wearing
like a Hans and Franz style like a
muscle suit like a grey muscle suit it
looks weird in a way so not green it's
great no cuz yeah because we don't
actually shoot with him we shoot a take
with him for reference and then we set
on landmarks and these guys basically
acting how hard is that for you guys
it's very difficult kind of hard
sometimes especially when Zorn is
walking around the room because we're
supposed to remember points on the wall
of where we're looking winds wounds
talking and we're looking at nobody and
we're talking to nobody
that's when we do this we do like he's
crossing and now huh nice well later in
the season Dan just that he'd be in the
middle of a line and suddenly you'd be
like crossing to fridge I'm sitting and
standing and we're like oh I was harder
to work with Zorn or Larry David Larry
David Wow we actually have a clip of son
of Zorn so let's take a look at
I'm on my way to Orange County to see my
wife and kid they're gonna be so pumped
nothing more emotional than a soldier
coming home all right
by the way I'm sore defender of superior
conqueror of the tribes of agon
Decapitator of the dark herdsmen oh I
know you're fake sleeping you haven't
seen us in 10 years it's hard to even
have this conversation right now
because I want a hot pocket so bad and
it's all I'm thinking about what I can't
get him where I'm from you got a job in
town itself is called Sanitation
solutions
my boss looks and talks exactly like a
woman he carries a purse he uses tampons
darn can I speak to you for a second
what you're describing as a woman no no
son you're not listening he's my
superior hey you're a good guy this
bundle Edie remember that time we had
that fivesome with those mountain trolls
that was the old me sex with the
mountain troll Craig this is my fiancee
thorn it's obvious that you're applying
way too much pressure to my hand right
now and actually it hurt it does
assistant of Linda
looks to me like it was done with a
giant sword do you know anyone in the
office who would do something like this
um first thought Margie and H are there
is nobody named Margie who works in this
office oh look I know I've been the
perfect father but al angle on is still
my son if I could just get him out there
on the battlefield I know he loved it
what do you think it's all yours now
look it's an older model but it handles
great on murder swoops I mean you're the
world's greatest dad
what do you think I should do I know you
haven't always had a great relationship
with your dad but he got a job he got an
apartment he freed all his blades I
think he's really making effort to
change food waitress yeah we're
gonna both have the rib eye how would
you let that cook ah not I think not
right I'm a vegetarian
what the hell is happening
what why why fun fine you know you got
you got passion firing if you don't get
rid of this thing right now I'm calling
animal control oh no no this bird would
kill animal control I'm not kidding why
what was painless didn't feel a thing
I've done this a billion oh here we go
we're like how funny was gonna must be
weird acting and seeing it right first
time I've seen it no it is it is really
weird seeing it because like we say we
we when we shoot it we're like talking
to no one
like we're you like yelling at an X on a
wall you know or you like talking really
nicely to an X and it's like it's a
really weird you know one thing that's
really good is that Barry will have
he'll have a sort of a rough animation
the short is sort of like whatever
having directors yeah and so and so that
way we get a feeling for like you know
what's happening in the scene you know
so that's been really helpful and
sometimes there's there are animated
objects which is also adds to the crazy
yeah there's a lot of interactivity
these guys hold car seats and holds real
things and could we go to his cartoon
world right now this close our eyes and
go to Sofia I imagine that if this goes
well which I looks like it's gonna like
there's a lot to explore and both the
real and cartoon universe in this
in this world but we can take them to
his world Oh season two that would be a
lot easier to just put them on
green-screen oh my god that'd be a dream
then the animators have to deal with all
of it but but there are a lot of guest
star animated characters on the show so
so so sometimes I don't want to learn
but we have his date so now you're
looking at two nonexistent two exes on
the wall yeah and on set now there's two
people in gray sweat suit so it really
is pretty cool huh
it looks freaking hilarious but the show
like actually deals with some heavy
stuff an absentee father and husband
um how grounded you keep it or is that a
tough balance to address those type of
issues as well as killing a giant bird I
think we've always tried to do is keep
it grounded and relatable and and kind
of all the stories really stem from a
relatable place and then the challenge
has been we see we keep wanting to push
it further and further and we try and
pull it back but at the core of it it
really all is relatable stories like one
one thing is we have Zorn an
ex-girlfriend comes back like a toxic
girlfriend except she actually is
radioactive so it's kind of like it's
it's stories you'd see on other on other
shows but it just has this unique twist
and there's one episode - where one is
orange friends come back come to visit
us and we find out that he has a problem
with alcohol and so it's his animated
character who's actually an alcoholic so
it's pretty but you know but it's like
what we deal with it like sort of like
you would deal with the character for
real like if it was a real person yeah
yeah and just like with that bird - it's
you know that the tone of our show would
be real easy to go super big and he's
killing this bird and everybody's
freaking out and but they're just
annoyed that he's making a mess in the
driveway like in the reality of this
show funnier that way there's an island
of cut you know this island of cartoon
characters you know they're in this like
fantasy world that Zorn comes from and
that's just the reality that everyone
buys into so people are aware of these
things maybe they've never met anyone
from
area or scene one of these birds in
person but it's not like a big crazy
person from Maine like you don't know
any people from Maine yeah I don't know
anyone from Maine
I don't react to me no no no I mean it's
pretty normal but I don't know this
stuff is reminiscent of it's from like a
genre yeah yeah yeah yeah we play off a
lot of tropes of you know from family
sitcom type shows like the bird the bird
showing up it's almost like bringing a
new car to like impress your son yeah
and you know I mean as a parent everyone
just tuned out but but it is interesting
because when you're growing up and
you're a teenager and you have parents
that embarrass you all the time it's
hard and on this show like we kick it up
a notch because not only the this does
he have me nursing but now as ORN you
know shows up at his high school to help
him or Tim will show up to help organize
the prom but just humiliating things
that people would not want but because
it's son of zoran and the writers are
amazing they can take it to a heightened
reality where everyone can step back and
laugh at your pain hey Johnny it's on my
pin tell us about the most painful
memories you tap into to get in touch
with too much our saddest story okay
when I buried my dog because my dad
wasn't home that was the thing to bury
the dog I thought I was setting you up
for a bit yeah I couldn't think of any
bits I got saved up Johnny yeah you're a
true you're an actor you're true action
thank you
and it'll remind all so reminds me a
little bit of like just taking a
character like this a little bit of some
Harvey Birdman dude well what other
shows like tonally I mean if our city
man right I'm not specifically I mean
you know it's all
it's it's all from that from that genre
not you know er er is a big influence
you know a lot of people see it and say
ask that he-man question I think when
you see the show and see especially
house on behaves there's you will not
draw that comparison ever really is
boring ya know in Zafira aware Zorn
lives he is he's like a conqueror and
he's kind of the hero of his own story
but he's not necessarily like what's a
squeaky-clean
you know like good guy he's a barbarian
he killed a bird in the pilot what's a
FIRREA like what I want to go on
vacation there 8 hours yeah yeah so it's
a very violent place and all they do is
kill each other and destroy everything
there yeah as if it'sif area is an
island that exists in the Pacific Ocean
it's this is just surrounded by real
water but it's this cartoon Island and
there's you know ice caves and there's
lava pits and there's zombies zombie
stabbed with Columbia stir like the
generic thing that horn always kills
it's sort of like the like a goblin or
something you're like the first level of
a video game it's a thing you just hack
and slash yeah that's a glom beasts are
sure to me that's what they are they can
be anything but there's a lot of killing
in Sofia it's a lot like Detroit thank
you good night everyone
that's awesome
and how many how many episodes are in
the first season 13 13 even in the cam
yeah how many hoes you got in the cab
you got 13 in the can right you know
that's the crazy thing about the show we
shot all of it just this complicated
process we we finished shooting maybe a
month ago but we're only up to Episode
five they've only started animating
maybe up to Episode four or five so it's
it's like making two shows it takes a
full year to make thirteen episodes
we're not gonna shoot in you know
shooting schedule for
13 and then it's like show number two
starts the animated portion of it Wow
and I'm Wichita premiere September 25th
right after the Simpsons September 20
fan on Fox September 25th yeah hey
September 25th
let's all be there yes all right you
guys this was super fun thank you for
taking time out of your comic-con to
come and visit with us and what an
amazingly talented funny cast and
creators thank you let's have a round of
buzzer son of George thank you of course
thank you for watching bye bye bye bye
thanks again to mafia 3 we're sponsoring
this episode to watch our previous show
click the box to the left and to see
everything from screen junkie central
click the box to the right